well that's also something where uh you
know before when i've been on the show
we were talking about
uh the heart of everything that is about
red clouds in the in the western sioux
oh that's in india that's the name of
the book the name of the book is the
heart of everything that is
i wasn't getting super meta holy smokes
the heart of everything that is is a
great book about this uh
sue from the lakota nation this chief uh
red cloud
and something that i love about those
books is that they're like hey listen
native americans did [ __ ] up [ __ ]
right like they would gang rape
they would smash babies into rocks and
yes but it's like because everybody was
a piece of [ __ ]
yes at that time yes everybody was
everyone was doing [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and like even the farmers were like well
what are the fire they're [ __ ] sheep
they're doing something you know
something where you're like this is
crazy you're doing it it's like you
can't deny like things like
slavery and beating your wife and all
that all these things are bad things
but guess what african-american africans
were selling other africans into slavery
it's just
it's either somebody else does it or you
do it to your own that's just how the
human brain works and like
gandhi had [ __ ] 12 year old wives
it's like cancel everybody then
i'm trying to tell you when anyone when
anyone tries to tell me like if i
was like yo i loved sincerely louis c.k
like i love that new special and people
are like
you watch that i'm like yeah do you
listen to the beatles
cool john lennon beat the [ __ ] out of
his wife yeah like are
we gonna play this game yeah you're i
don't believe in domestic violence
i think louis did a [ __ ] up thing but
i think you're worse yeah you're
supporting a
monster a monster but it's like you're
gonna you're gonna be able to [ __ ]
cancel
everybody dude it's like what do you
want me to tell you that that's why i'm
like i go by the person i don't care
about the
race religion creed it's like people
make mistakes not everybody's all if
anybody's
appears to be 100 perfect stay away from
them
man do not go near the people who appear
to be perfect because they're sinister
scumbags one of the biggest life lessons
you can have is
never never trust a man that doesn't
have a shadow yeah
i never trust someone that's not like i
did this [ __ ] up [ __ ] cause then
you're like
what are you and then you find out that
they have children bones buried in their
backyard
yeah dude because it's like even elvis
was a pedophile
what elvis mary elvis married priscilla
when he was 24 and she was 14.
wow look that [ __ ] up there you go that
is on record
so i love to see all these people that
are like i got a graceland every year
and you're like cool he was [ __ ] kids
in that house yeah
you know yeah they wouldn't call it
epstein land and you're like
whoa it's just like he also stole black
music
like the guy [ __ ] took black music
and everyone's like this is how you do
it
i know dude people there it is there's
him with his child bride
yeah oh do you ever have a wife that's
afraid of the dark oh
he just has to do stuff well come on
baby here's your juice box
come on priscilla was she 14 or am i
wrong what she was
so that she does not look 14. yeah they
grew them different back then
i loved that so it's like because you
were dying in war when you were 17
yeah so it's like but that's the thing
like times just change and now times are
changing
so quick and we have to adapt to things
so quick that something you did last
week
was legal and now you do it it's like if
you you could get canceled you can lose
your whole career your [ __ ]
freedom because it's scary i've said
this before but
just to wrap up like the whole canceling
thing especially being a comedian
that we are like we're just trying to be
funny all the time and we're not
necessarily thinking about how this
could look
right retroactively but i think um
you got to look at it as a comedian it's
like we're smokers and you might get
cancer
cancer is getting canceled it's like
sometimes you can fight it sometimes it
kills you
you know but it's like we're out here
ripping butts and it's like something
one of us
we all might catch it who [ __ ] knows
my aunt colleen's listening to this
episode like i like that dance oh
[Music]
thank you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed the last video don't forget to
tell your friends
like subscribe and turn on notifications
[Music]